- I'm an attention arbitrage entrepreneur.
(upbeat music)
- We are the breakfast club,
got a special guest in the building!
- [Co-Host] My favorite
corporate thug motivator is back!
(hip hop music)
- The next trend is meditation.
If you wanna get real smart,
so back to hey give us a
practical piece of advice,
if you're intrigued by mental health,
I'm super intrigued by this issue.
So I think mental health
needs to be the number one
thing we talk about over
the next twenty years.
Mental health is something
we need to put on a pedestal,
and really start talking about.
Meditation is a huge
opportunity, everybody's
gonna be doing it.
If you're operating system isn't right,
if your brain's not right,
nothing else is gonna work.
If you're a business person,
if you're startin' a juice company,
if you're tryin' to flip sneakers,
and it's 100% about the money,
you're gonna lose.
If you don't love your process,
if you don't love eating
the shit along the way,
you got zero shots to hit that huge level.
If you don't like takin'
a thousand free throws,
if you don't like being in
the office until midnight,
if you don't like waiting in
line for six hours in the cold,
to get that thing,
you're finished.
The people that are winning
are the ones who wake up at
4:30, take two trains, and
get third in line and love it.
- [Radio Host] Gary V
ladies and gentlemen!
- [Co-Host] My guy!
- It's the breakfast club, good mornin'.
- What up vlog, I'm really
gonna miss the things,
tomorrow's the big day,
the launch of my sneaker
and my Jackie Robinson year,
number 42.
So lookin' forward to that.
By the time you watch this
it was already my birthday
so in the comments you
can go with happy belated.
(dinging)
(upbeat music)
- [Male] As far as
tasting shit is concerned,
I wanna taste as much of it as I can,
in as many places as I can.
- Interesting.
- [Male] What I'm gonna
do is travel the world.
- I love it.
So what's the plan?
In detail.
When do you start traveling?
- [Male] January 12th.
- And where you goin'?
- [Male] Beijing.
- And what are you doing there?
- [Male] Teaching three to
five year old kids English.
- I love it.
- [Male] I love your
thoughts on this idea.
With personal branding in mind,
I realized that I don't
necessarily wanna be the
person marketing someone else.
- You wanna market yourself?
- [Male] I wanna market myself.
- I understand that.
- [Male] Yeah.
I obviously need to have
time where I can say
something worth a value
that actually helps people.
- Or you document versus creating, right?
I think it's super
appropriate for you to talk
about the one year in China and like
get a homie to help you
or you do it yourself
like Casey does of like
all those journeys and
learning things and struggling
with learning Mandarin
and I didn't know how
hard languages were or
you know, my God, this kid in my class
understood English in one
day, he's a fuckin' genius or
I tasted this fruit and what the fuck.
The big thing I push against
and this is good clarity
for everybody watching and you,
is just when people front
and they think they're
business expert or a life coach at 22,
it's tough.
It's tough because other
people look at that and say,
- [Male] They can smell the bullshit.
- Yeah, you know what, listen.
Talent is talent, maybe you're so wise,
I feel like I was an old soul,
so maybe you can be a life coach at 22,
it's not for me to judge.
I think that people do it
for the sake of selling
some program for $1,000 a month.
- [Male] Which isn't my end goal at all.
- And by the way, that
doesn't bother me either,
it's just that I see a
lot of people building
a personal brand with one agenda,
to then monetize that audience
in some sort of horse shit thing.
So to me, I don't think you
have to eat shit for a decade.
You don't have to do my narrative.
I'm not sure if I would
have stayed quiet from
22 to 34 if all this existed.
But what I do know is I
wouldn't be acting the way
I'm acting now, I'd be talking about,
first of all I wish it
happened because then
everybody would have
really saw how fuckin' hard
I was working.
But I think it's super
appropriate to document man.
I think the documentation
creates the origin story.
When you can recall shit
at 29 or 34 and literally
play the clip of the first
time that you use AR in Asia,
got it?
That's why it's important.
What people don't realize
about what I'm doing right now,
is this is fuckin' awesome.
Ten years from now this
make this look like shit.
When I'm recalling shit.
- [Male] And recalling the recall.
- Do you know how crazy
it's gonna be when fuckin'
voice rules the world and I
show this entire fuckin' year
of me spitting it?
It's one thing for me,
it happened the other day.
Those musically tweets, late at night,
of me talkin' about
musically two years ago,
and putting musically
on and believing in it,
and then it sells for a billion dollars,
a hell of a lot better than
when I tell people I like
invested in Facebook and Twitter,
'cause that's me telling you.
Me showing you, plus
it's also cool for life.
You're grandkids, are you kidding?
In China?
That's fuckin' rad.
You know?
So I would create as
much content as possible.
That would be my advice.
It's a real pleasure
man, good luck to you.
Thanks for everything.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
(upbeat music)
- Anything I can help you
with in the few minutes
that we have here?
- [Male] Yeah, so I think
my biggest concern right now
is getting a team.
So it's hard to hire people
who are actually skillful
at the right price, 'cause like.
- Can you teach it quickly?
- [Male] Yes and no.
I feel like I can teach it.
- Let me ask a better question.
Can you fire quickly?
Are you allowed in China to fire?
- [Male] Yes.
- Then that's what, then you're lucky.
If you were in fuckin' Norway, or Europe,
France, you're dead with my thesis.
I've got a great answer for you.
Fire quickly.
I'm giving you my advice.
Eating my own dog food.
I go on gut, Kyle, I keep pointing at him
'cause he's filming it, I'm goin' on gut.
I had a phone call with
him, I had a drink at a bar
with him and I'm like, "You're hired."
If he sucked or was all
time it would have both
made sense to me.
If I fire quickly, he'll
work for me for nine weeks
but I'll give him a
three months severance so
I feel like I'm a good guy.
You know?
So I didn't fuck him up too much,
or I'll know their situation,
like if I hire somebody who like,
had no options in life, I'm like, look.
It's not like I took 'em away from
Harvard Business School.
You know, I'll play the
reality of the situation.
I think that's what you do man,
you fire quickly.
- Here in Bangor video with--
- What up everybody?
Hope you guys are doin' your thing.
One life baby, take advantage of it.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo!
- [Host] What's up bro?
- [Gary] What up baby?
- This is the ambassador of arbitrage,
the hiram leader of hustle,
Gary Vaynerchuk is in the building.
What's up man?
- Life is good man, thanks for havin' me.
My legacy of like putting
people on and bringing value
while I got mine,
is gonna matter exponentially
more to me than the
dollar amounts.
You listen,
there's a lot of people who
are gonna make more money
than me.
But I really, really, am
gonna try to make sure
nobody has a bigger impact than me.
- [Host] That's some fly shit.
- It's why I'm passionate
about doing stuff like this.
I, after doing a quick
audit and kind of intuition
of like I knew I wanted to do it,
do you know how pumped I
am I'm doin' this show?
Do you know why?
'Cause I want you to use
me as a guest of this
to get a different level of guests
to get you to the next place.
I know where I came from,
and giving back to that thing
is the most interesting
thing in the world.
And the amount of, in a world
where my hour is my fuckin'
- [Host] Yeah, that's
a lot of time for you.
- You know, to me, if you
ask me the thing that's
most interesting for me,
it's the emails you're gonna
send to the other people
or people when they look, you know?
Brand arbitrage.
I think my bigger advantage was my mother.
If you ask me what's a
bigger advantage to why
I'm gonna win?
It is way more my mother
than being a white dude.
'Cause she fuckin' set me up.
Real proper.
So I think your mother,
and I'm talkin' about
everybody who's watching,
or your father if he was the stay at home.
Whoever raised you.
Let's go cliche, or
your grandmother, right?
Let me go to every angle.
- [Host] Let's go some more.
- Right, right?
That is bigger,
is a crazy variable in the
way that I see the world.
The person that was the
puppet master of your mindset
positive or negative.
My grandmother fucked my dad up real good.
And my dad won,
but she was negative.
Everything was bad.
Don't believe in anybody.
Everybody's jealous.
Everything is bad.
The world's out to get you.
And watching my dad filter the world,
I'm like fuck man, I'm glad I
don't see the world that way
and that has nothing to do
with black, white, girl, boy,
so, that's how I see it.
Everybody's reality is their reality.
Like they don't know.
Like it's tough, nobody
can be in anybody's shoes.
Nobody was with me when I
was crying to my mom like,
at 18 I would cry to my mom a lot.
The last time I really cried a lot except
when Garrison Hurst
broke a 99 yard touchdown
in 1999 against the Jets in week one
in overtime, I literally cried.
I was 24 years old, just
so everybody understands.
Anyway, I didn't want to go to
my dad's liquor store business.
The great struggle of my early adult life
was knowing that I knew I
was gonna be all time great.
Knew it.
And I knew that if I went
and got into my dad's
liquor store business that
people would dangle it over
my head.
But I knew that I wanted
to right by my dad
and mom 'cause they did so right by me.
To ever apologize when you
don't do the wrong thing
is a wrong strategy.
- [Host] You're right
it is, I never say sorry
for something I don't do.
- And by the way, on the
flip side on love those
rare occasions where I get to say sorry
'cause I'll say it.
You gotta own your shit.
No body fuckin' listening
or watchin' this is perfect.
Baseball cards, wine, the
agency and even me as a human.
I'm doin' the same shit over and over.
I disproportionately understand
what people are gonna
do before they do it.
I'm willing to eat shit and do the work,
not just pontificate about it.
And then I deploy that
attention of those executions
against the the thing.
And then I got smart seven
years ago and said fuck,
let me build a machine around this skill.
Vander Media is the
manifestation of the the platform
that is basically my one thing.
And my one thing is intuitive
understanding of what
people are gonna do before
they do and go it all in.
Investing in a Twitter and
Tumblr and all this stuff
right, that's what I did.
- [Host] If you were to die
tomorrow, what would you
wanna be remembered for?
- That I gave more than I took.
- I have a thing that I'm doing.
That I started when it comes to education
called Black Boys Win.
Almost like a Udemi for young black boys,
manhood training, things of that nature.
What do you think I need
to do to raise the funds?
- How much do you need?
- Right now I need 15 grand.
- I'm in.
- I'm sorry, what?
- I'll pay for the whole thing.
- Get the fuck outta here.
Is this tape rollin'?
Son of a bitch.
- Now do somethin' with it.
- Man trust me.
I will.
That's amazing, like thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Host] Very famous shook.
Thank you bro.
- You're welcome bro.
- [Host] I appreciate that man.
- See ya.
(upbeat music)
- [Nicole] Hello?
- What's the name again?
Nicole, hey, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and you're on the Ask Gary
V show with Tim Ferris.
- [Nicole] Oh my God, I'm losing my mind.
- If you're tried and true,
the market will come to you.
What is super interesting
to me about hip hop is
it is now an absolute fundamental
pillar of our culture,
across all genres and it
stayed true to itself,
it evolved.
But the world came to hip hop,
hip hop didn't go to the world.
And I realized as I got
older, oh rock and roll
did the same thing.
And honestly, that's
what happened with me and
entrepreneurship.
If you believe in your
thing, stick with it,
and the world will come to you.
If you're passionate
about cricket protein,
this is not a joke by the way now,
this is actually something
that I think is gonna
work out,
if you're passionate
about cricket protein,
bet the farm on it,
because if you see it and you
understand why you see it,
it's gonna be a lot of
fun in nine years when
we're all eating it.
And you were there, not
because it's not selling
right now, most of things
that have brought good
to Tim and I,
'cause I can definitely
speak for myself but I've
watched from afar and
sometimes close with Tim,
people weren't super
sure about at the time,
we're playing on being
historically correct,
hip hop was historically correct.
On this episode, the incredible
Timothy Ferris stops by.
(upbeat music)
- [Male] Gary?
- Yes?
- [Male] Can we go over
an article really quick?
Not an interview, but.
- Yes, give me one second.
Here it is, givin' away these shoes,
who's getting these?
Some great kid.
First pair I ever wore, being shipped out
this is one of the great
reasons to be part of
my notification squad on Instagram,
make sure you set you notifications,
60 second club.
We're just having fun with it,
it's a lot of fun.
Gamification, just like fun.
Literally fun needs to be part of it.
I think it's funny that you
have to comment in the first
60 seconds, I don't think
there's any big strategy,
you know, I don't think
it brings any value,
I think the value is fun and
escaping something fun is a big thing, so
turn on your notifications
on Instagram I'm always
doin' a ton of stuff.
First pair, is this going in this box?
Switching out?
First pair I ever wore,
getting sent out.
Do you know his name?
- [Male] Muhammad Hosan.
- Muhammad Hosan, enjoy
it brother, love you.
- [Male] For his younger brother actually.
- Oh is that right?
Even better.
Listen get a good look at
this, maybe there's some
sort of scuff that people
can prove this was,
actually,
go get me a pen or some sorts.
Yeah.
Here it is.
O O 1.
First pair.
There it is.
Let me put it on this one too.
Hassan or his bother,
you might be able to make
some money on this one day
if I can continue to
bring value to the world.
- I have complete understanding
that what I'm saying
doesn't always encompass
everyone's specific
circumstances and want to
acknowledge that I'm doing
the best that I can.
At it's most basic form,
I wanna use some of these
ideas and expressions to
further conversation or
allow someone to experience
the personal unlock
to see things different or
with a different perspective.
I just want you to look at the bright side
and to the best of my ability
inspire others to have
access to another mindset
that I found valuable in
my own life.
As a practitioner of these ideas,
I'm trying to give you
advice that's worked for me.
The reason I differentiate
my content is so that
I can have a great
articulation on a number of
specific issues.
With video you get to
hear what I'm saying.
Which is always improvised
and only captures my
thoughts in a single moment.
One of the things I find most fascinating
is that even though I document everything,
you still only get to
see one to 2% of what's
really going on.
You are hearing one
sentence in one meeting
during one day.
The funny thing is the vlog
I produce is only 15 minutes
of the 15 hours of work.
All in all, you actually
don't get to see that much.
So the reason why I do a
podcast and a vlog and full-time
Instagram and produce these
articles is so I can give you
the most nuance to my ideas
and to respect the creator
and the differences of each platform.
Quotes on Instagram might not
always capture the full story,
which is why I write these
articles to expand those ideas
and go deeper into the details.
You have to analyze context
and look at the bigger picture.
I'm always trying to assess
what works in culture
and deploy my creative in a
way that make sense for the
context of the Rumin Pumpkin.
Currently full time
Instagram would be work.
They're one piece of the
puzzle that have enormous
impact for what I would consider the most
motivational side of me.
The vlog, podcasts and
articles are where I can get
tactic way about what
I'm trying to convey.
I can't write 10 pages on
legacy and put it on Twitter.
I can't always articulate
all of my thoughts and
keynote ranger media.
Those nuances and that
context is really, really,
important.
A lot of people wanna judge
me and make assessments
with a single piece of content they see,
but the truth is it's all about context.
You have to watch my
videos and read my articles
and listen to my keynotes
to really understand
my tweets, my quotes or
two minute videos online,
that's where the message
is, that's where the mindset
comes in pretty.
- Put in quotes there, in
parentheses or something there
and also say, "Or you
don't because I know you
guys have options and time,
but to get the full picture
that's the reality of the situation.
It's like a great
meal at a restaurant.
You're more than welcome to
just judge it on the green peas.
Without taking into consideration
the glass of Champagne
that we gave you when you first walked in,
the music that was playing,
the smiles from the bartender,
the color of the linens,
the peas, before mentioned
peas, as your first dish,
the main course, the
dessert, the wine selection,
the service,
and the treats we sent you home with
and the follow up phone call
we gave you two weeks later
to see how it was, you
didn't see the whole thing."
That's how I think about
my entire content strategy.
It's cool right?
It's true.
Fuck, you know what's even more true?
You guys both consumed
my content a lot of it,
and you had no fucking idea
until you got the vortex.
Even remotely close to how
deep and real it is, right?
- [Male] Yeah I always
tell people the difference
from consuming it to
working directly with you
and filming it.
- Yeah the filming is the crazy what?
What's the most intense?
Here give me this.
This is gonna be the meat of the episode.
So, filming it, what?
- Basically just I get
to observe every moment,
every minute, every meeting,
everything you mumble,
everything.
- [Gary] So what's the early
observations of what that,
what does that give you
clarity into or what's the
observation, and don't
sugar coat it to be nice.
- Well basically I went
from consuming it as a fan,
and online mentor to then
working directly with Gary, with you
to then filming it being on the inside,
seeing the way your mind
runs, your whole thought
process behind everything in the meetings,
all the conversations you have.
- [Gary] So what have you learned?
- Well one of my favorite
things to do while filming
you is just observing what you observe.
So for instance, today
you had the first podcast
that you did.
- Gary Vaynerchuk is in the building.
What's up man?
- And you mentioned
something about the shoes.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And you were gonna
give him a pair of shoes.
And then you, once he said.
- [Gary] 13's?
- Yeah he said 13's.
- [Host] I don't have any
sneakers but I wear size 13.
- Respect, get it done guys.
- And then he said surprise
me, whichever ones.
- You want the leather or the flyden?
- [Host] I'll let you pick, I don't care.
- You looked at his shoes.
- [Host] Second thing.
- [Gary] Oh.
Good job, I'm proud, dude
you just made the vlog good.
- You looked at his shoes
real quick and I know
just in my mind, told me
like you just wanna check
out his style.
- [Gary] So you know what that his?
You know how I always talk
shit that I'm listening
more than it looks like,
that's a perfect example.
- Those are the things I always look for.
- [Gary] You just made the vlog good.
Cool.
Let's go.
What's it titled?
- [Male] My content is a mindset.
- Great, let's go.
Publish it.
(dramatic music)
- Do you know if I had a
wish besides good health for
all of you, is that I wish
people understood what they
felt like when they were older?
That would be such a gift,
'cause it would slow down
the whole game, you'd be
so much more thoughtful
because that's what
you're running up against
when you're, when it's early.
You know, dollars, or
things that you, you know,
what ever checkbox your
family and your DNA created
in your mind and we're racing against that
and it's such a short term arbitrage,
and it creates such bad behavior.
If you guys knew what it
felt like to be 15 years
older than you are right now,
you would get real patient and that would
give you huge advantages.
Wrapping up, heading home, family stuff.
(dramatic music)